Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Öncelikle hoş geldiniz.
Ben yasakları delmek için varım.
(Alkışlar)
Bursa'da bir Tedx konuşması
bana teklif edildiğinde,
ne hakkında konuşayım
diye düşündüm uzun süre.
Sonra dediler ki bu yılın konusu deneyim.
Ben de o sırada Kanal D'ye henüz
Genel Müdür yardımcısı olmuştum.
Oturdum 2 gün düşündüm ve dedim ki;
ben şöyle bir başlığı olan
bir konuşma yapmak istiyorum;
"Deneyimsiz eleman aranıyor."
(Alkışlar)
Herhâlde aranızda bugüne kadar
iş başvurusu yapmış olanlar vardır.
Görebilir miyim iş başvurusu yapanları?
Şahane, peki iş başvurusundan
ret cevabı alanları görebilir miyim?
Bayağı iyi.
Peki deneyimsizlik sebebiyle ret
cevabı alanları görebilir miyim?
Oysa bana gelseydiniz
hepinizi işe alırdım.
(Gülüşmeler) (Alkışlar)
Çünkü ben,
deneyimli insanların kendilerine bir
konfor alanı yarattıklarını düşünüyorum.
Ayrıca çok fazla kibirli
olduklarını düşünüyorum.
Ayrıca yeniliklere
açık olmadıklarını düşünüyorum.
(Alkışlar)
Bunu nereden biliyorum kendimden.
(Gülüşmeler)
Ama sadece kendimden değil.
Burada mutlaka işverenler vardır.
Bir onları da görebilir miyim?
Bakın bunların hepsi
kendi popolarını sağlama almak için
kendilerine konfor alanı
yaratmış insanlardır.
Net.
O kadar net ki ben de öyleyim,
kendimden biliyorum.
Ama deneyimsiz insanlar;
yeniliklere açıktır,
cesurdur, yenilikçidir.
Mesela kendi hayatımdan örnek vereyim
yeniliklere açık olmakla ilgili.
Biliyorsunuz ya da
bilmek zorunda değilsiniz ben,
İstanbul Üniversitesi
Hukuk Fakültesi'ni bitirdim.
Onun üstüne de Uluslararası İlişkiler
masterı yaptım.
Sonra işletme doktorası yaptım.
Şimdi de sosyoloji öğrencisiyim.
Hukuk Fakültesi'ni bitirdikten sonra
3 yıl kadar ya da 4 yıl kadar,
bir inşaat şirketinin
hukuk müşavirliğini yaptım, İzmit'de.
Sonra dedim ki; bu küçük yerde bana
bir hayat yok, ben İstanbul'a gideceğim.
Ve İstanbul'a gittim.
3 yıl kadar işsiz kaldım.
Ama iş arıyorum yani.
O zamanlarda bir yasa var:
5 yıl avukatlık yapmış olanlar
direkt Adalet Bakanlığı'na başvuruyorlar
ve sizi hâkim ya da savcı olarak
direkt atıyor Adalet Bakanlığı.
Şimdi de galiba öyle
zorunluluk tam bilmiyorum.
Ben gittim dedim ki iş bulamayacağım
Adalet Bakanlığı'na bir dilekçe yazdım.
Ama dilekçeyi unuttum gitti ben.
Sonra benim çocukluk arkadaşım
bana dedi ki;
-Gel, Med Yapım diye bir şirket kuruluyor,
bir televizyon şirketi.
Orada bir hazırlık elemanı arıyorlar,
orada sana bir görüşme ayarladım, dedi.
Gittim, görüştüm bana dediler ki;
- Gel pazartesi günü işe başla.
- Ne yapacağım, dedim.
- Hazırlık elemanı olacaksın, dediler.
Eve gittim evde kapıda bir tane
pusula, resmî bir şey olduğu belli,
çıkardım baktım.
Şöyle yazıyor; Sayın, Armağan Çağlayan
lütfen Sahra Cidi karakoluna geliniz...
Ciddi korktum,
karakol falan karışık işler.
Karakola, girdim,
ağabey acayip bir şey oldu;
bütün polisler ayağa kalktı
önünü falan ilikliyor,
Armağan Bey hoş geldiniz diyor.
Önce bir anlamadım ne olduğunu.
Sonra komiser geldi,
bir kağıt uzattı önüme.
Atama emri, Ali Armağan Çağlayan;
Şırnak Cumhuriyet Savcısı
olarak atandınız yazıyor.
(Gülüşmeler)
Şimdi biraz önce de
hayatımda hiç bilmediğim
bir iş yerine kabul edilmişim.
Televizyonculuk diye bir şey o zaman yok,
yani çok yeni Türkiye'de
özel televizyonlar
ve ben hiç bilmiyorum öyle işler.
Bana dedim beş dakika izin verin.
Dışarı çıktım o zamanlar cep telefonu
filan yok, ankesörlü telefonlar var.
Bu salonun yaş ortalaması yeter herhâlde.
Bir jeton aldım, annemi aradım.
Şimdi büyük ya annemize danışacağız
deneyimli hayat konusunda;
anne dedim böyle böyle,
iki seçenek var:
Ya Şırnak'a gideceğim
Cumhuriyet Savcısı olacağım
ya da hayatımda hiç bilmediğim bir işi
yapacağım ve televizyoncu olacağım.
Benim annem öğretmen, hiç düşünmedi,
Şırnak'a git dedi tabii ki
savcı olacaksın, dedi.
Telefonu kapattım annem böyle diyorsa
tersini yapmam lazım dedim.
(Gülüşmeler)
(Alkışlar)
Ve atama emrini imzalamadım,
televizyoncu oldum.
Bakın; işte bu deneyimsiz insanın
yeniliklere açık olmasıyla ilgili bir şey.
Oysa bugünkü aklım olsa,
aynı şey bugün başıma gelse,
bu kadar, 25 yıldır
televizyonculuk yapıyorum,
ne yaparım biliyor musunuz,
imzalarım ve Şırnak'a giderim.
Çok ciddi söylüyorum bunu.
Deneyimsiz insanlar bence
deneyimli insanlara göre daha cesurlar.
Televizyonculuğa başladım o zaman
doktoram var ama kimse beni takmıyor.
Elime bir tane otobüs bileti veriyorlar,
- Git Eminönü'nden top al gel, diyorlar,
ben gidiyorum Eminönü'nden
top alıp geliyorum,
böyle işler yapıyorum.
Huysuz Virjin de
namıdiğer Seyfi Dursunoğlu,
bizim şirketle anlaşmış,
benim çalıştığım yapım şirketiyle.
10 bölüm bir bizden önce
televizyon programı yapmış ama
parayı da cebine koymuş yeni
transfer olmuş ama sürekli şunu söylüyor;
- Benim malzemem yok,
10 bölümden fazla bir şey
yapamam ben, diyor.
Gitti bizim şirkettekiler
Gani Müjde'yle anlaştılar.
Şimdi Gani Müjde deyince,
hani Gani Müjde yani...
Gani bey bir şeyler yazdı getirdiler.
Şirkette okundu, herkes
karınlarını tuta tuta güldü.
Sonra bunu Seyfi Bey'e götürdüler.
Seyfi Bey dedi ki;
- Bunlar olmamış.
Sonra Necef Uğurlu'ya gittiler.
Necef Uğurlu çok şahane
şeyler yazdı gerçekten.
Bunu yine Seyfi Bey'e götürdüler
Seyfi bey dedi ki yine;
- Bunlar olmamış.
Ben de hep bunları dinliyorum,
oturdum orada bilgisayarın başına,
ofiste bir köşede bir şeyler yazdım.
Seyfi Bey'in kostümlerini
yapan patronun karısı vardı,
yani bizim şirketin patronunun karısı.
Ona dedim ki;
- Bu yazılanları götürüp
Seyfi Bey'e verir misin?
Seyfi Bey şöyle yapmış okuduktan sonra;
- Bu çocuğu bana getirin, demiş.
Ben gittim ve benim televizyonculuk
kariyerim öyle değişti.
Deneyimsiz insan her zaman daha cesurdur.
Bugün olsa bu deneyimimle
hayatta hiç kimseye bir şey yazıp
beni de dene diye yollamam.
Çünkü kariyerimi kaybetmekten korkarım.
Çünkü güvenli alanımı
kaybetmekten korkarım,
çünkü reddedilmekten korkarım.
Ayrıca deneyimsizlik,
insana çok acayip bir saflık,
bir hümanizm kazandırıyor.
Bu salonda hepiniz ilk Popstar'ı
kuşkusuz seyretmişsinizdir.
O zamanlar biliyorsunuz
şarkı yarışmaları Türkiye'de yeniydi.
Jüri kavramı Türkiye'de yeniydi,
yarışmacı olmak Türkiye'de yeniydi.
Biz dört jüri üyesi,
gittik Türkiye'nin çeşitli yerlerinden
13 tane insan seçtik.
İşte o bildiğiniz ve unutamadığınız;
Bayhanlar, Firdevsler hepsini
hiçbir hesap kitap yapmadan.
İşte mesela şunu düşünmedik;
Bayhan'ı seçelim de Bayhan da
öteki Türklerin kahramanı olsun,
onun karşısına da beyaz Türklerin
kahramanı Barış'ı koyalım,
bir de kadın kahraman;
Firdevs koyalım diye düşünmedik.
Gerçekten onları
istediğimiz için onları seçtik.
Ve bize gelen yarışmacılar da
son derece deneyimsizliği ile
hayatında ilk defa bir şeye katılmak için
bu yarışmaya gelip başvurdular.
Birincisi acayip başarı kazandı
sonra ikincisini yapmaya başladık.
Mutlaka görmüşsünüzdür İzmir'de
ilk elemeye yedi bin kişi filan geldi.
İşte bütün gazetelere bu manşet oldu;
Popstar umut dağıtıyor filan diye.
Sonra bütün jüri üyeleri büyük
deneyimimizle şunu yapmaya başladık;
şimdi biz bunu alırsak
bunu Bayhan'ın yerine koyarız,
bu da Firdevs gibi bu,
bayağı bütün deneyimimizi
aslında kötüye kullandık.
Sonra yarışmacılar da
deneyimli gelmeye başladı.
Bayağı kavga çıkartmak için gelen,
işte bana laf sokmak için gelen.
Bursa'da kafama ayakkabı bile attılar
Saddam'a ayakkabı atıldığı dönem,
(Gülüşmeler)
ciddi söylüyorum.
Bursa'daki bir elemede, o zaman
Saddam'a ayakkabı atmışlardı.
Yarışmacının biri söyledi,
ben olmadı dedim.
Ayakkabıyı çıkarttı bir fırlattı bana.
Ve iki yarışma arasında
şöyle bir fark var.
İlk Popstar'da hem jüri deneyimsizdi,
hem seyirci deneyimsizdi.
hem yarışmacılar deneyimsizdi.
Ama ilk Popstar'a bir eleme gecesinde
gelen oy miktarını söylüyorum;
iki milyon iki yüz elli bin sms.
İkinci Popstar'da jüri deneyimliydi,
yarışmacılar deneyimliydi,
seyirci deneyimliydi.
Gelen oy miktarını
söylüyorum; bin beş yüz.
Şimdi, deneyimsiz insan mı iyidir?
Deneyimli insan mı iyidir?
Kuşkusuz deneyimsiz olmak
deneyimli olmaya göre bir avantaj.
Ben gerçekten böyle düşünüyorum.
İlk Popstar ile ilgili bir
deneyim hikâyesi daha anlatayım.
Bayhan yarışıyor.
Bayhan’ın kuzeniydi galiba,
kuzenini kazara
öldürdüğü ortaya çıktı.
Bütün gazetelerde manşet;
Bayhan Katil.
Şirkette olağanüstü toplantı yapıldı.
Ama hiç öyle toplantı gibi değil,
- Ne yapacağız, dedim ben patrona.
- Hiçbir şey yapmayacağız,
çocuk çıkacak, olanı anlatacak, dedi.
Bugün olsa sosyal medya uzmanı,
halkla ilişkiler uzmanı,
kişisel gelişim uzmanı
ve o olay çözülemez biliyorsunuz.
Böyle kördüğüm olur bırakılır.
Ama o gün o olay orada bir gecede çözüldü.
Çocuk çıktı dürüstçe anlattı;
- Evet kazara kuzenimi bıçakladım,
o da kan kaybından öldü, dedi bitti.
Bugün sekiz tane uzman bu olayı
çözmeye çalışır ve çözülemez.
Gerçekten çözülemez.
(Gülüşmeler)
Şunu gerçekten söylemek isterim ki;
deneyimli insanlar, kendi konfor
alanlarından kurtulamadıkları sürece,
bu, deneyimsiz insanları işe almamak
meselesi de sürüp gidecek.
Benim beyaz yakalılara naçizane
kendimin de arada sırada denediği
ama arada sırada denemediği
bir şey önermek isterim.
Lütfen konforlu alanlarınızdan kurtulun.
Her sabah yatağınızdan kalktığınızda
deneyimi yatağınızda bırakın.
Ama iş yerine bütün
deneyimsizliğinizle gidin.
Ve burada deneyimsizliği yüzünden,
iş başvurusu reddedilenlere
söylemek istediğim şeyler var:
Lütfen üzülmeyin.
Siz yeniliklere açık, işbirliğine açık,
efendim, zihni bizden
daha açık insanlarsınız.
En son yapılan araştırmaya göre,
insanın karşısındaki insanı dinleme süresi
ne kadara düşmüş biliyor musunuz?
Sekiz saniye.
Ama bu sekiz saniye bence
deneyimli insanlar için.
Benim de karşımdaki insanı dinleme sürem,
belki sekiz saniye bile yok.
Ama deneyimsiz insanlar bilgiye
ve işbirliğine o kadar açıklar ki;
sizi sıkılmadan
3-4 dakika dinleyebilirler.
Gerçekten buna inanıyorum
ve bir yazarın dediği gibi,
bütün deneyimsiz arkadaşlara
şunu söylemek istiyorum:
"Lütfen korkmayın,
tökezlediğiniz yerde hazineniz vardır."
(Alkışlar)